what else we got nick oh oh [ __ ] damn no
yeah
are we going what are we doing what are
we doing yeah schultz can start i
open i just yeah you open your gift and
then oh and this is the gift okay
so this is my gift this is part of my
gift right this is it it goes
live to me uh live to make people laugh
i can't read that's fire thank you very
much for the camera can you see the
camera
okay i'll show it to the camera sorry
which one am i this one this one here
look at that oh that's a bad one that's
cool
who brought that i did oh
thank you man someone mailed that to me
i have no clue sent it to me either
thank you this is a lot of smoothie
mixes oh that's athletic greens
cats they give us if you want more promo
code cats and liquid iv
yup stay hydrated all right you and your
girl in hawaii
there's one more thing this is uh dustin
poirier's
[Laughter]
dang i wish i had to put some i'm gonna
open mine now i got these baby
somebody gave me this oh damn damn
that's mine
so i uh damn baby in the punk rock world
we used to wear bullet belts
that's a belt yeah it's a belt you don't
wear around your neck you're wearing
around your head damn hot topic was open
during these hours
a thought topic brother those are those
are real bullets so yeah
be careful so don't get too hot in those
44s or something i don't know
my buddy gave me that uh 48. back in
like 0-9
what did that say on the bottom 48.
that's dope i wish we would have played
this white elephant
i know yeah that's actually yeah
percocet all right open this one hit a
shot
let's go shabba
dang what's this anyone got keys
get in there hey what'd you get man
this one's for me this was your gift
yeah
and we got christmas bonuses for
everybody on the show too so we just
want to let you all know that
oh [ __ ] sick who said [ __ ] sick
nick he's [ __ ] sick nick's always
about goddamn time
he's like nah that's cool though oh this
is cool
show us princesses
[Laughter]
what is it the hottest have you ever had
one of those i don't do that
that'd be a great entry i don't play
that [ __ ] do you want one you wanna go i
do not play that you like views
can you do it alex can eat spicy stuff
do you want to try it
half half half i wouldn't even have the
little tiny little piece
come on al take a bite come on now come
on come on
come on come on out yeah out directed oh
my god
special al directed it how directed it
yeah how would this because
directorial debut was a netflix special
oh hell yeah
i'll give you this we've all done it to
be honest the fit is clean
the pine jordans come on son come on i'm
gonna be leaking out my ass
no you know i'm not girls don't don't
touch your eyes or anything after
yeah yeah don't don't i'm not having any
of it no
i'm not having it yeah i already did
yeah direct us through this bruh yeah
direct us through yeah
real quick real quick who's this from
china here we go alex media has taken
down the hottest chip in the world
challenge
[Laughter]
the real challenge is not to have any
fluids that's what the tic-tac-toe yeah
you can't have anything in that ride man
but you're a guest so do whatever you
want
yeah yeah we're not telling you now wipe
your hands before you touch your face
you don't want to get that
[Laughter]
i drank [ __ ] room temperature milk to
get over it and i got real sick
yeah the milk was the bad choice yeah
what else we got chapelle do you open
yours up
uh i got chins just opened it up okay he
re-gifted
i got myself 3d printed okay
from last year from last night okay chen
that's awesome that was a good gift
yeah i'm glad i got it is he crying he's
crying bro
i can't believe you took that much shaq
couldn't do that right didn't shaq start
crying
i don't know did he do it yeah still
cried you cried on that i think i did
but i cry usually every other episode
i i i panicked at first i panicked
is it still there it is it's not going
away no it's really not
it's gonna be about an hour yeah
20 minutes you're going to get a second
hit no it comes back strong
and then when you hit that toilet son
that's not true i think you're going to
be fine and i think these people are
overreacting
oh my oh you're right deal didn't eat
one no it's just white people trying to
scare you bro that's what it is
and we've seen enough of that [ __ ] i
think it is now we have with this covet
[ __ ]
yeah chappelle you got one you got one
oh yeah
oh man this one i brought for you
so in the asian community we hate the
sun because we don't want to age
and we wear these visors hell yeah wow
so you're going to look like
every old asian lady in the park doing
tai chi
super asian gift that's super
damn dog make some weld some jewelry son
that shit's dope
dude you gotta [ __ ] work with nelly
now yeah you gotta get in there doc
i know it's [ __ ] up bro cover your
face dude
did you go through your face that's how
cat's gonna introduce you to her family
that's a great gift man
hey kat have fun in the movies in 2022.
there's gonna be some good stuff coming
out looking for the avatar three yeah
yeah yep
we think they're special by then so i
can go watch it yes it will be in
theaters
yeah it'll be only intense style switch
it up
you think they they zig you zag yes hey
i can see that being a thing where
specials the first place they come out
is maybe in the theater
remember when martin did that back in
the day when we were younger yeah martin
had one come out eddie did probably been
a long time all right
a year ago that's right yeah no even a
few years ago
we were in high school he did no he did
a year ago though
yeah okay what else oh damn chin also
gave me
pretty dope earbuds oh that's cool
that's like that's nice of you
this is like michael scott bringing that
ipod
and sardines and ramen and sardines and
ramen oh you got that
yeah that's a dowry kid in asia it is he
marries someone you give that in asia
yeah dude that's [ __ ] hell yeah you
get two [ __ ] you give that in asia
i do what'd you get thank you brandon
his cbd company
yeah that's not the new new but it's
cool
that's overstock but yeah kratom
me and chen are addicted to kratom yeah
we are amazing i'm that powerful
is a supplement that's supposed to help
your brain how would you describe
how would you describe your chin uh
it's just a powdered leaf it's from a
tree it was used in thailand for
thousands of years
they say it's kind of like the fda wants
to stop it because it gives some sort of
an opiate
type of effect but means it's supposed
to be safe it's natural me and chin like
but it's actually really good uh if you
want to use it for pain and for
you know anxiety i i take you before i
see the stage yeah it's like cbd all the
time
and they just have to take it every day
otherwise you go through vital
withdrawals
yeah that's the part i mean some people
some people do but then that's why you
got to just watch yourself
violent withdrawals or just don't do it
if you don't need to vernon's next
comedy show
withdrawals that's a great special title
[Music]